[Music]
we have not seen Richard Simmons since
2014 and accusations have been made that
Richards housekeeper is keeping him
hidden well as for that hostage claim
well Richard flat-out denied that to us
after we tracked him down via phone a
year ago no I'm not kidnapped I'm just
in my house right now and Richard has
denied other rumors surrounding his
mysterious public absence rumors like
he's transitioning to a woman suffering
from depression and hiding out after
weight gain why still weigh 150 Richard
had said that he just wants a break from
the spotlight so where is he and who was
with him well there's been a lot of
activity outside of his home and
Hollywood Hills this week we spotted a
second housekeeper a pool man and his
longtime assistant Michelle Mads that
was Tuesday and this was Matt's joking
around with Richard when we visited him
in 2013 and 2014
Richard apparently ended a friendship
with this man Morrow Oliveira was also
Richards massage therapist he has to
have his identity hidden for our sit
down yes we have a lot of friends over
all the time gin there parties all the
time I know perfect that he is stopped
talking to many loving longtime friends
Richard's closest bond appears to be
with housekeeper Theresa this morning
the man behind a popular weekly podcast
missing Richard Simmons sat down with
Wendy Williams as I was getting to know
Richard we my husband and I went over to
his house for dinner
Richard served dinner Richard made
dinner
Richard cleaned up and Teresa the
housekeeper sat at the head of the table
it's true
[Music]
Oh